en juillet dernier marc alexandre
paquette participe à un jeu concours sur
le site de la compagnie couche tard il
en profite pour tester la sécurité des
données personnelles comme son numéro de
téléphone qui lie à l'essai sur l'espace
de six jours le prix quand j'avais écrit
purement celle au dessus de 100 mille
numéros de téléphone seulement le québec
je le vois aussi si j'allais faire le
qui j'ai utilisé aucun mécanisme de
contournement tu partais partir d'ici
l'adresse ip aucun proximité des choses
comme s'il y avait plus facilement
bloquée ou non de racailles qui est
effectué chamité bloggie marc alexandre
paquette s'empressent alors d'alerter la
compagnie en envoyant ses messages où il
indique clairement que le concours
comporte des failles de sécurité
j'ai eu qu'une réponse venant locaux
nous avons communiqué avec la compagnie
qui a d'abord assuré qu'il n'y avait
aucun problème de sécurité
le site du concours a toutefois été
fermée par mesure préventive
puis après avoir vu un extrait de
données provenant de son site la
compagnie couche-tard à trouver la
faille
marc alexandre paquette affirme qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'un cas isolé puisqu'il a
déjà observé d'autres problèmes de
sécurité sur d'autres sites
cet expert en cyber sécurité est du même
avis aucune surprise
ce genre de truc qui arrive beaucoup
plus souvent qu'on pense ce genre de
données l'eau peut devenir rapidement un
système de clé en main pour les
fraudeurs aussi parce que c'est de
l'information nominatives sur les
personnes même si on n'a pas toutes les
données à leur civique ou non peu
importe on a assez de données pour
potentiellement fraudé quelques heures
ils lancent d'ailleurs cette mise en
garde faut prendre pour acquis vraiment
que l'information qu'on donne en ligne
même si ça peut être aussi insignifiant
guimaëc participants au concours a su
mixa weitz usa vont scruter un jour
couche-tard assure qu'il n'y a eu aucune
fuite d'information et sousse et mener
d'autres analyses approfondies de
sécurité éric naufrage au canada
montréal